[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update
about the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
Happy birthday, TensorFlow.
It's been a year since
your open sourcing,
and you're the most popular
machine learning project
on GitHub.
Take a look at
this post to learn
more about where TensorFlow
has been and where it's going.
Also on the ML
front, take a look
at this article for all the
updates to the Google Cloud
machine learning family,
including a new API, pricing,
and GPUs.
The post has all the details.
And if you're new to machine
learning all together,
perhaps you'll want to
start by just playing around
with some experiments.
Well, you're in luck.
Our friends at The
Creative Lab have
released some really
fun experiments
with machine learning.
You play with them
right away or go deeper
with the GitHub links.
A video with the details
and links to the experiments
are on the post.
Distributed denial of
service attacks are bad,
but they're arguably worse
when they're self-inflicted.
To avoid this common software
architecture design failure,
take a look at this post
from our customer reliability
engineering team.
There is now an officially
supported Firebase Unity SDK
that provides packages for
Firebase features on iOS
and Android, including
Firebase Analytics,
the real-time database
and dynamic links.
To get started today,
head on over to the post.
And if you're new
to Firebase, you
may want to take a gander
at this new Udacity
course, "Firebase in a weekend.
It'll help you understand
many of the core features
of Firebase by building
an app from the ground up.
The slide's API V1 is
now generally available
and represents the first time
that developers have ever
been able to programmatically
access slides.
To learn more about
what this API can
do with code and a video,
head on over to the post.
Please subscribe and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hey.
Thanks for watching the show.
If you'd like to see
some other episodes,
click on them right here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]